one time I was flirting with this girl
and we were walking and I legit crashed
into his side maybe I should give
lessons on how to fail at getting a
girl's number I'm really bad at flirting
a guy calls me babe and I spend the next
two hours googling what that could mean
so awkward when people flirt with me boy
you're pretty me happy birthday to you
as well I tried to flirt with a really
cute guy am i checkout lane
turns out he's a doctor and he thought I
was suffering from a form of anxiety
attack I told this cute girl I liked her
accent and a squirt was from she said it
was a speech impediment my flirting
skills in a nutshell met a really cute
girl she started to flirt with me and
that's what my name was my response I
don't know
I just tried flirting with my fiance he
got confused and couldn't catch on so
now I'm just eating Doritos at least
they understand what I want in my mouth
one time I was flirting with a guy and
he said I'm loving the whole blond hair
blue eyes thing and I said so did Hitler